introduce hi i'm eric i work at bol.com
currently as the head of data science
where i'm tasked to make sure that as
the company we make the best use of data
science in general
before
i was acting as a
there we go
as a product manager so the the bottom
left bubble we saw in the previous talk
and have a formal background in applied
physics so always trying to understand
how does the world work
and i think that's in essence also what
data science is trying to do trying to
understand the process that you're
working with and how that translates
into what we do
and
one of the reasons why i love doing this
at
ball.com as a quick introduction of
what we're doing
is
we're trying to realize our mission
to together change retail and make
everyday life easier
and
the reasons how we do that basically is
to look at what people need
and how can we better accommodate for
that
and to make it more tangible if you look
at what we've done over the last
21 years
you see that we've typically added more
and more to our offering and
i'll not go too much into the top part
of adding what we are selling
but i'll go more into the actual
bottom part where you see where we have
added ways how we bring things to you so
we're not only selling products but
we're also bringing you digital products
we're no longer
shipping things through a single
warehouse we have three four or five
warehouses to bring stuff to you
and we no longer have a
single language application but we're
now also moving into the french speaking
part
of belgium
and
the reason why that's interesting in our
context is because every step that we
add
adds complexity
so for instance imagine the warehouse if
you just have one warehouse where you
can stock your goods
it's easy to tell to a supplier bring it
here
if you have two of them it's a choice
if you add one more warehouse
that's not a simple choice anymore one
two three but your complexity actually
skills exponentially
and that's the point where
a technology like data science can
actually make a profound difference
because you can skill with that
complexity
as it comes to you and you can continue
to offer a differentiated retail
offering to your customer and as such
change retail
and we've been doing that on a wide
range of applications
already throughout the store
so think about
product recommendations product search i
think classical
fields where
we help you to find the goods that
you're looking for
think about fraud and risk management
where we try to feel try to find people
that are doing malpractice
at scale and always beating them in the
cat and mouse game and we're doing it
within logistics
to make sure that we can keep pushing
the boundaries on not only getting the
goods to you in time
but also getting goods to you
efficiently so not a single item in a
box like that but making sure they are
packaged in a way that we don't ship too
much air and produce too much co2
and
the reason why i'm giving you all of
this background of how ball.com works
is because basically this was the
the origin of why the list came to be
and the list i'll be talking to you
about is
what we have learned
to make data science come alive in
practice effectively
because we found that to do this at
skill to have this application you just
saw
run across 20 teams
we needed to decentralize
the discipline
we needed to make sure that
not a single centralized team did data
science for everyone because that
doesn't skill we needed to make sure
that everyone could do this at their own
pace
so we saw that
skill
means decentralization
but it also comes with a challenge that
if you have indie data science
everywhere if you have many teams doing
this it's hard to keep them aligned
it's hard for them to
to learn what one team learns across
teams it's hard to make sure that if you
ever want to switch teams you come into
a place where you have a common way of
working common tool set a common way of
um how indeed you do for interview email
ops sequence we just saw
and
to make sure that
we are not only aligned but together are
raising the bar
we set out to
describe a set of
learnings we had
across these teams
because if you think about how does
learning work
it's very simple um basically
you make a mistake
you think hey wait this is not the
intent that i had you think about how
can i change the way how i got here
and you look at did it change the
outcome and of course in this example
it's a very simple one
here you would for instance
change how you put on your sweater and
then check again
your label
if you were to find again a label on the
front end
you would think hey maybe i go shopping
for spiders at the wrong store
but that's the thing the moment you have
insight
the moment you figure out why something
went wrong
you can change your behavior but that's
something you can share that's something
that you can share with different teams
and once you share that
basically they can make the change
before actually they are making the
mistake and as such indeed learn
together
so this is the whole reason why we set
out today and this of course still dry
matter and i'll try and make it more
common alive with the actual list itself
and
do note that when we're setting out to
create this one
we ask a lot of people okay how should
this look like what should be part of
that and of course then you get a lot of
people in a lot of opinions with
not always the most
condensed way of telling it it needs
something data yeah but what then
yeah but data is important
yeah that's kind of in
the name of data science so we got that
so what does it mean and after
a few rounds of iterations we actually
got to his first implementation of the
list which
i think as a title
tells you it's it's not complete
it's something that will be changing
daily weekly and for the
the careful reader you'll find that
compared to the outline that you had
before pi data
what you'll see today is actually again
an iteration on top of that
because everyone that reads the list
adds something to it removes something
through it to improve on it and that
would be my question also to all of you
today is please share what your thoughts
are
please share what appeals to you please
share what you recognize from your
company in the intent to make this
better
and
um
two footnotes for that one
is that do know this we have written
this within the context of ball.com
which is an online retailer which allows
you to do
certain things that you friends you
couldn't do could not do in for instant
healthcare we saw earlier this morning
and it also indeed allows to work within
the structure that we have with teams
as such for instance this would not
translate that well into academia for
people doing their phd for instance
different contexts different settings um
and the final thing we said is we're
going to constrain these two six
we're going to have six items
if you ever want to add a seventh
we're going to say okay this is going at
the expense of something else or we'll
merge it
just to make sure that the list that we
have in the end is not just a huge csv
you could actually do data science on
but a list of six items
[Music]
so what i'll be doing for the rest of
the talk is
a condensed version of the actual list
itself
and then for two of them go more in
depth and tell war stories of
either how we've learned it the hard way
or how we've applied in practice to make
sure that
we actually got to benefit from it
and
this is the one that we ended up with um
a list of six
phrased sort of catchy
but below it a lot of things actually
should be able to help you in your daily
practice when putting data science in um
when
trying to create value out of data
science
and
um first one off and i think we've saw
on that i've seen that a few times
already today is make sure that you
understand your problem um
because
there we go um
because it allows you to do two things
one it allows you to solve the actual
problem at hand and i think uh vladimir
just now already mentioned it well is
the best way to solve the problem is not
by a model but actually removing
something that's that's creating that
be sure to do that
but also you need if you understand your
problem you're trying to solve for a
customer then you within your team can
decide autonomously
what the best way to solve that is
and that's i think what you immediately
reflected in
the bottom part
is if you want
if you want to understand your problem
you actually need to understand context
you need to understand your user you
need to understand
why they use excel that many of us hate
but there's a reason for that
so that means sitting next to them
whilst they're doing their daily job
doesn't mean it's asking questions that
means putting yourself in their
perspective
which choices they make how why are they
hard what are
the upsides of downside or getting it
wrong
and it also means that
if you understand the problem and you
see a different way to solve it
you need to challenge your users on how
to do it differently
that's when you become most effective
not saying oh is this what you need oh
i'll make that for you now challenge
them think along with and to refine what
you're actually trying to solve
i'll get to this one more in a deep dive
later
the second one is
feel fast to learn fast
this is something that we've learned
time and time again basically this means
that
if
you put something out there in a very
rough form
it allows you to correct direction fast
hey i thought you meant this right no i
meant something else ah okay that's cool
because i haven't invested a lot of time
yet i can easily course correct
um
and the second thing is it allows you to
validate con assumptions we think this
helps doesn't it
if it turns out it doesn't then you can
course correct fast without indeed
having constructed a full pipeline or
invest a lot of time in
exploring data if one of your key
assumption doesn't work
it doesn't work
what does this mean
this means that
you need to show stuff to your team to
your product owner to your product
manager to your users which isn't done
yet
which isn't refined which isn't polished
which can go wrong which might be scary
which might reflect poorly back on you
but that's worth it at the expense of
the feedback that you will get
and not wasting time in any direction
that is not the intent of your user's
problem
and the second thing that you need to do
is you need to think out loud
you need to
allow people to look in your brain which
they typically can't
after all data science is not brain
surgery so you need to help them there
you need to think out loud on where's
your mind what what's the direction that
you have where do you think is the right
solution
and by doing so you allow others to give
you feedback on your direction and again
that's something that takes effort that
takes time
but it always pays off
and as an example
this is one actually the first one of
the very first versions that um i showed
to people when whilst creating this list
just a few stickies just a few scratches
just
and already get tons of feedback and
only after that you go into the fancy
panty powerpoint animations which in the
end don't work
next one i picked the right tool
we've heard this i think a few times
over
it won't be the first time that someone
tries to solve a problem with a neural
net which they could have done with
three lines of sql
and
the reason why this is so much important
to pick the right tool because quite
often you can already solve a problem a
lot faster
than you would have done otherwise
and that's time gained
and secondly by picking the right tool
you get to balance a lot better about
complexity of your tools versus the
features that you have
and
it won't be the first time that i saw
people um he'd start to
build an entire airflow instance
where in the end they had one job run
daily i mean that's what a cron job does
really well stick with that because
everyone understands that
the thing however if you want to do this
you need to be up to date on what's
there you need to be available you need
to know what all the tools that are out
there are actually doing that takes time
but that's time you always get back
either in new projects
or get back in just days of fun while
attending conferences like these where
you can do this
and secondly you need to make deliberate
choices and that's the thing typically
what i what you also see is that
every now and then you need to pick the
simple tool
to get started to get your assumptions
corrected to get insights in
knowing that down the road you need to
correct for that
but that's fine
and that choices typically also skip
the fourth one um leveraging
craftsmanship um it's a thing also we
just saw with vladimir right now um
already it's uh i think maybe the one
from this that i personally love the
most it's
there we go sorry
um
in the teams that we have if you need
you were to put people together with
different skill sets
you get to benefit from each other
you don't have to go for the
x-ops
unicorn registral but you get to hire a
software engineer that understands the
basics
of data science but get to bring the
expertise on
on versioning on how to build an api and
how to build a kubernetes cluster
so you can work together you can have a
data scientist that indeed
does the basics of
version control
asks if he has a tough merge conflict
and then puts his most time in
developing models
and
if you work like that
if you rely on each other to be
effective you create shared ownership so
indeed it's no longer
one person builds something he chucks it
over the fence and someone else then
puts it in production and if it breaks
you know they'll be pointing towards
each other and who's full of this by
working together like this you build
ownership
and especially in our case you can open
up the app and you can show that to your
mother and say we built this how cool is
that
the downside of that
is you need to trust your team
you need to be okay with the fact that
there are some parts of your product
that you build
that you don't fully understand someone
else does but you don't
and that's okay
it also requires you to
push back when someone tells you how to
do it
because as a craftsman typically you've
learned your job in 5 years 10 years 20
years of academic training or in the
fields practice
you know how to do things
so push back for people that say what do
you need what are your requirements
and then let me do my job
and this is the need where you get to
leverage craftsmanship and make sure
that everyone indeed does the thing they
do best and love most
fifth out of sixth and then i'll get to
the war stories and where it becomes
messy
um
something you see go wrong quite often
it takes more directed steps
and
why is this one so important because by
taking small steps i think by iterating
quite often um you get to reap
incremental benefits
and especially in a organization like
well of course we have transactions
daily if you get to improve one percent
today
we can already gain from that you can
already enthuse your users by having
something that works and having a model
on the shelf you need that could have
that benefit doesn't do anything so
small steps
and indeed iterate often
not with the fact
that all of them are beneficial but the
fact that you get to learn a lot faster
if you just take small steps does this
work does this work does this work
and it gets you the course correct
if you want to do this though you need
to know where you stand and i'll get
back to that one because this one deep
dives well and break down the work
more detail in the deep dive
and
finally what we've seen that a lot of
effective teams do is they excite your
use they excite their users they don't
say hey what do you want okay here's
your table of numbers good luck with
that but they make sure they go the
extra mile in making people happy about
what they get
so
um the point of this why would you do
that is this ensures that all the hard
work that you put in
actually gets adopted
it means that
if you have worked really hard to build
a forecast people actually start to do
planning based on that because they like
what they see
it's not just a table of numbers for
them anymore they know what has gone in
they know what it enables them to do and
they like it
and
if you like the first thing that you got
you're going to be curious about what's
more what's next what else can you do
for me to make my job even better and
that's i think typically the dynamic
that you would always like to create is
create pull from your users to
get even more cool products out there
which you typically get when you excite
your users
what is it required to do
do demos
show your work give people little
witches that they can interact with and
play around with for them to understand
and to see what happens
hey what happens if i put in this funny
word hey what happens if we have this
weird number come in and that's where
people start to understand the model and
start to have fun together
and
what this also means is that you need to
manage expectations
data science is not
magic that can make every problem go
away
it's not that oh we can forecast
everything within one percent accuracy
you can't
but you can manage expectations in such
a way that
you deliver on what you know people are
looking for and then go the mile beyond
takes work it can be done
then going for the second test and this
is i think france if you could help me
flip back to the other one
really curious is
i think this one is the point where
indeed it gets
broken we have a missing in the lines
that's okay um
i was going to do a first quick round of
interactions i think
it will not link because i have a
different code here than you have there
if you were to test it
you can give an answer
but most likely it will not show up on
the screen can we try that real quick
yes it is seven questions i know oh it
actually works oh cool
well this one is the first question we
need getting feedback from say the first
outside that you've heard which one
appeals to you most and which one do you
think makes perfect sense which one do
you think
i don't think this is the most important
thing
and here we see already a need on a
scale from zero to seven a few of them
scoring quite well
i think there's already a clear winner
in need on understanding what you're
actually trying to solve
and below that there's a struggle
be sure to fill this one out and i think
then um
you already have the second one there as
well
which i think would simply also be which
is the one that you're missing uh it's
fine to leave that one open just for the
next 10 minutes think about that hey if
i look at my context what have i learned
um is typically helping us the the most
and add it to the list it allows me to
incorporate feedback and to make it even
better
but with that let's switch back to the
um
to the slides there
um
and
take two examples to make these come
alive i know it's been already a long
day with lots of talks
and let's see you need a few of the use
cases where we've actually tried to
apply this
and the first one
is a case we did earlier this year
when we were
asked
by actually the government to help them
manage the whole kofit pandemic
uh they reached out to us a conglomerate
of a collaboration program
of five big multinationals so klm ns ing
philips and aldo hasem together under
the kickstart ai
program
to
help them look to incorporate all of our
knowledge and expertise about ai and ml
to help them predict what will kovhi do
in the netherlands
and as such
help them
manage the scarce resources in
healthcare to make sure that
we make the most out of that
and
[Music]
by the way combine those
five corporates
three governmental agencies and you have
13 days to build something that runs in
production
best of luck with that one
so here what we did is first things
first we wanted to understand our
problem what are we trying to solve how
does it work
and
the first one for us was clear
we needed to solve
or release
the pressure that was on our ics where
people with covad would be
assigned to beds
stay there for a while and if indeed
they were effort to exceed capacity
especially locally we could relocate
patients
and the better we know how to relocate
them the better it was
so that's the first bit this is what we
knew this work helping decision makers
manage covid in the hospital cool
the assumption there was is
we might have a signal that can help us
do that
because
we measure the um the presence of
coveted particles in our sewage water
across the country
that's something we measure we have that
data somewhere and that might help us
okay so we asked some questions about
how does that process work then and how
is that being done
but how does covet work okay let's dive
into that then and then we learned this
is what they call a infection pyramid
where
the basic understanding is that um
people get sick without symptoms
but from that point onwards you already
have virus particles
basically inner stool
already there but you might not even be
symptomatic
once you get symptomatic some people get
tested
some people that get tested actually are
infected some people that are infected
might actually end up in hospital
and some people that end up in the
hospital might actually also die from
the covet but that's basically a funnel
where
the number of people
diminishes over time and there's a
sequence to that
okay we have a rough understanding of
why
a sewage water measurement could help
predict this because there's a time
difference between those okay
let's see how we can use that
[Music]
so we sat down with the team
we asked everyone okay make us just draw
a draft based on your current
understanding of what type of
information and data would you like to
present to decision makers
to help them make that call
and
what we did here and it's not important
to see actual details but we ask
everyone just to draw their
understanding
and this allowed us to ask questions
why do you have disks why do you have
it for each bit of the country why do
you have
a top line well this is because i
understand it like this
ah you get to ask the details question
okay what metric am i seeing there
and this is the point where
as a team we found out that we're not
going to predict the number of people
that get infected
we're going to predict the number of
people that actually end up in hospital
for two reasons
one
we understood that that was the scarce
resources actually people were managing
and two we understand we understood from
how coveted works that that introduces
the biggest time lag
between when the particles are available
are already present in your stool
towards when actually things happen in
the hospital so you get more time that
to act that's what we were looking for
and all of that came from
from building understanding from having
that conversation and for just you know
having that conversation having those
talks and um
in the end
we ended up with basically an action
list
just like this so no kanban boards no
sprint things just this this was our
action list
with just one line of text
assigned to people
because people knew what they had to do
they knew the context they knew the
problem they knew how it was going to
work
and how they were actually going to
implement that that was up to them
in the end this worked out quite well
because currently indeed within 13 days
we offered the solution to the
government which is a fully um github
managed dockerized application that does
python for training and a fast api for
the dashboard that they have and we did
away with all of the pipelines we just
collected all the data every single time
you spin up a container for simplicity
there was not that much data
[Music]
and this is currently
live for decisions makers in terms of a
b testing
whether it actually helps them
and we managed that in 13 days
despite spending the first five of those
solely building our understanding and
that's i think where you can see this
already come alive
two and a half
including questions
alrighty then the one-minute version of
take smaller directed steps um
in terms of context we started off with
a forecasting team that would do ml
forecasting given that the entire
organization was doing forecasting in
excel
and they would send their excel results
back and forth by email
scenario version control
consistency
error prone excel sheets
so
we set out to help them
and the thing we learned here and then i
think this chart actually summarizes
most is if you were to ever change
people or want to help people with an ml
problem
be sure to always act in one direction
either in the direction of performance
or in the direction of process
and
do that many times over so iterate over
those
time and time again
in order to come to a solution
and
every single step
should be in one
direction
and as an example
if you were to change a forecast from a
weekly to a daily level
make sure the numbers add up to your old
forecast if people compare them they're
the same it's just going from weekly to
daily if you move from excel to
someone's being computed on the cloud
make sure the numbers are the same so
you just change the process
if you were to ever change an old profit
model to a
arena based model or a deep ar
make sure that you keep everything the
same but the number so people can
compare them
that helps you in adoption
and make sure things go
fast
and the final one um to keep in mind
here
know what your target and your benchmark
is
in these steps
make sure that performance wise
you go to the point that you're actually
at the same performance at the current
state or slightly below
and if you're there only invest in in
process
because that's where you need to invest
to get people um on board to adopt your
process
we did this time and time and again and
our current situation what we've managed
to do is not only have a centralized
forecasting team that supports i think
over 80 percent of our operational teams
but also allow them to be interconnected
so if we change a feature in our central
forecast we know every downstream
forecast
is also affected and improved
and we would not have gotten to this
major step from local desktop-driven
excel to essentially managed forecasting
team if you would not have taken small
directed steps
with that um my final question would be
if you still have the app if it runs
please drop in all the feedback that you
have because that's the only way i can
make this list even better
thanks